[Música]
y nos vamos directo hasta la ciudad de
los ángeles en eeuu donde allí a partir
de hoy lunes es 6 de junio inicia
entonces esta novena cumbre de las
américas ahí se encuentran en asamblea
especial natalia cabrera a natalia la
saludo muy buen día le pregunta entonces
quienes ya confirmaron su asistencia a
la cumbre y quiénes eran los grandes
ausentes de este evento
raúl buenos días pues empiezo por los
grandes ausentes todo empieza con el
anuncio de la administración de joe
bailan de que probablemente no iba a
invitar a las delegaciones de cuba de
nicaragua ni de venezuela por sus
prácticas antidemocráticas luego de que
se conociera esta declaración a pesar de
que no hay lista oficial de invitados el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador dijo que no iba a asistir si no
estaban presentes todos los países del
hemisferio esto hizo que países como
bolivia con el presidente luis arce
honduras con xiomara castró e incluso
argentinas en un primer momento dijeran
que tampoco iban a venir aquí a la
ciudad de los ángeles para esta novena
cumbre de las américas a raíz de esto
empezaron una serie de movimientos
diplomáticos por parte de la casablanca
que por ejemplo envió a buenos aires a
una delegación que habló con el
presidente alberto fernández para
convencerlo de la importancia de su
presencia aquí en la ciudad de los
ángeles también vimos movimientos
diplomáticos como la flexibilización de
algunas de las sanciones
venezuela y a cuba para tratar de
incentivar la presencia de los otros
países de la región que se sumaron de
alguna manera a este boicot que inició
el presidente mexicano
con continuo respondiente la pregunta
sobre quienes iban a asistir ya
confirmaron su presencia por ejemplo más
recientemente surinam que es uno de los
países de que integra la comunidad de
estados del caribe caricom que se habían
unido al boicot de anv lo inicialmente
que ahora vemos esta ruptura con
diciendo surinam que si va a venir a los
ángeles también el presidente de
colombia iván duque el presidente de
chile y el presidente de panamá que
precisamente estos dos últimos llegan
esta misma noche a la ciudad de los
ángeles sin embargo recordemos que hasta
el día miércoles no habrá un diálogo de
alto nivel entre presidentes por lo cual
aún es posible que varias de las
delegaciones confirmen natalia vamos a
hablar ahora de las protestas y los
llamados de varias organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos a que
se tomen medidas concretas en materia
migratoria no otro tema protagonista el
que se está hablando pues también fuera
de esta cumbre y que se espera que
toquen los mandatarios
si raúl es que precisamente a raíz de
esta posible ausencia de méxico que como
sabemos es uno de los principales países
tanto que genera migración como de
tránsito e incluso receptores de
inmigrantes
varias organizaciones de latinos
viviendo aquí en la ciudad de los
ángeles han convocado manifestaciones a
lo largo de toda la semana para exigir
que este a pesar de que es uno de los
temas principales de la agenda se ha
incluido también una en la declaración
final que es el documento que se espera
resulte de esta cumbre muchas de estas
organizaciones critican que no esté
presente el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador sino su canciller
marcelo ebrard y piden además que se
tomen en cuenta estas decisiones que se
mantenga su presencia en esta cumbre
debido a la importancia en este tema
para la región este llamado ha sido
replicado por organizaciones defensoras
de los derechos humanos como human
rightswatch que hace un par de horas en
la noche del domingo publicó un
comunicado en el que pedía a los
presidentes de méxico y de eeuu que
tomen medidas nuevamente respecto a este
tema
y denunciaron además en los tratos
inhumanos que están viviendo los
migrantes tanto en la frontera sur de
eeuu como en la frontera sur de méxico
donde llegan muchos solicitantes de
asilo y tienen que permanecer allí hasta
que se resuelven sus solicitudes este
tema de la migración como lo mencionas
es uno de los principales temas en la
agenda que inicia hoy con el foro de la
sociedad civil que es organizado por la
organización de estados américanos en el
va a estar el secretario general de la
organización luis almagro y se espera
que participen varios defensores y
activistas por los derechos de los
migrantes para exigir nuevamente que se
incluya una declara en la declaración
oficial soluciones para este flagelo